5 26 on your monday morning what's
driving you crazy we got a viewer with
an eye on a speedometer wondering hey
where are the blue and red flashing
lights and he writes i'm new to las
vegas and there should be more police
riding speeding tickets people drive too
fast even in heavy pedestrian areas like
parking lots oh also you can't see
painted street markings that can cause
accidents where's street maintenance
first of all annie welcome to las vegas
and thanks for watching 8 news now that
speeding subject it comes up a lot here
at what's driving you crazy as you can
see from earlier tweets the nevada
highway patrol definitely goes after
freeway speeders area police have told
us in the past that with their current
resources their attention is sometimes
drawn to other crimes but they do target
specific enforcement areas from time to
time as for those street markings i'll
get an update on the upkeep of local
pavement signage and get back to you in
a future report thanks again for writing
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me traffic eight
at eight news now dot com